hey guys now you know that i've been
talking a lot about the importance of
drinking enough water on my channel on a
lot of videos
but did you know that if you don't drink
enough
your body will show you yes there are
signs that your body gives you that
tells you hey you need to drink water
fast so in this video i'm going to show
you what those signs are let's get to it
[Music]
hey just in case you're new here i'm
daniel and welcome to my channel
subscribe if you like it now let's start
with the first sign that shows you that
your body is dehydrated and that you
need to drink more water
muscle cramps the nerve signals from
your brain to your muscles need fluid to
work properly and if you don't give your
body the water that it needs it reacts
by giving you cramps
remember if you workout you sweat and
lose fluids
this then creates an imbalance of
electrolytes in your muscles and it
increases the pain you will feel in your
muscles the next day
[Music]
your urine is dark colored
now of course this is actually
plain and simple if you don't go to the
toilet often that means you're not
drinking enough water and when you do
the color of your urine will be more
dark now of course there are other
things that influence your urine as well
the color of it for example certain
medications but in general keep an eye
out for it because it will remind you
that you need to drink more water
[Music]
headaches have you been experiencing a
lot of headaches this might be a sign
that you're not drinking enough water if
your body does not get enough fluid it
lowers the amount of blood and oxygen
your brain gets causing inflammation
fatigue
are you one of those guys who are always
tired you don't know what's going on you
get enough sleep you do everything you
can but you're just tired all the time
well are you drinking enough water
dehydration influences every aspect of
your health and that of course
influences your sleep as well you might
also feel exhausted when you need to
exercise
drink more water
dry skin and lower skin elasticity
you'll know when you start to get
dehydrated you'll feel it your skin will
be dry your lips will be dry and you can
test your skin's elasticity take hold of
the skin on your lower arm between two
fingers and then release it after a few
seconds normal skin will return quickly
to its normal position but dehydrated
skin will not
sweets now this is a strange one but
it's true you will start to crave more
sweets and other foods if you are
dehydrated
look
your organs need water to function
properly so for example your liver if it
doesn't get the water it needs fluids
then it struggles to release glucose and
other energy so what does your body do
then it tells you it needs more energy
and we as humans what do we do when we
need energy we start to eat
we especially crave sweet stuff
dizziness you know that feeling when you
stand up too quickly and you get dizzy
yeah it will happen a lot more if you're
dehydrated and be careful because severe
dehydration can even cause you to faint
feeling thirsty this one is just common
sense if you feel thirsty that means
that you are thirsty your body needs
water and don't go and drink soda don't
go and drink coffee or tea drink 100
pure mineral water
now if you guys want more health tips
watch one of these videos and you might
like it and remember to subscribe i'll
see you guys in the next video and
always remember before you go
life is short
so don't waste yours cheers guys